We finally figured out what’s been making
a huge greek letters by the north and south
poles.
My money’s on frat guys.
Hey there my shining beacons, Julian here
for DNews.
I’m sure you’ve all heard of the Aurora
Borealis, or if you’re a viewer south of
the equator, the Aurora Australis.
They’re dazzling natural light shows that
happen when charged particles like electrons
and protons from the solar wind excite oxygen
and nitrogen in our upper atmosphere.
Normally the Aurorae can occur 65-70 degrees
north or south of the equator but they can
happen at higher latitudes.
Occasionally these take the shape of the greek
letter theta and we had no idea why.
You see, the earth is surrounded by a magnetic
field thanks to its spinning iron core.
These magnetic field lines loop between the
north and south pole and form the magnetosphere.
The magnetosphere deflects the charged particles
of the solar wind, and it’s the reason we
have an atmosphere while poor little Mars
has had its almost totally stripped away.
But the field lines don’t all connect, and
plasma rides the broken ones down to the ionosphere,
getting faster and more dense.
When it meets our air energizes the gases,
which then radiate that energy away as light.
Normally the plasma that moves to the higher
latitudes cools but sometimes it gets more
energetic and makes these theta auroras.
Combining data from the European Space Agency’s
Cluster satellites and NASA’s IMAGE satellites,
the mystery of why this cold plasma heats
up and forms this shape has been solved.
As it turns out this plasma gets trapped when
broken field lines close, and it causes them
to become relatively hot again.
See what you can do when you work together?
It’s another nifty trick of nature and I
don’t care how good your fireworks are on
new years, nothing beats charged particles
from 150 million kilometers away traveling
down a magnetic funnel to make green and red
ribbon light shows in the sky.
If you’re a crazy person like Trace then
you want to shoot rockets at everything.
He explains why the Aurora should be one of
those things over here.
Is there another natural occurrence that boggles
your mind?
Do you want us to look into some other mystery
of nature?
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.